hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about the ten common causes of
inflammation okay number one low
cortisol that would be adrenal fatigue
what is cortisol it's an natural
anti-inflammatory it's the
anti-inflammatory of the body when you
run out of it like an adrenal burnout
you're going to need prednisone or
cortisone cream just like a lot of
people take when they have chronic pain
so low cortisol that comes from chronic
long-term sustained stress low cortisol
you're going to have our amalga and all
sorts of inflammation okay number two
old injuries I've had a lot of old
injuries old injuries create trauma and
scar tissue the scar tissue is heals
well the body heals of scar tissue in
the scar tissue does not have the amount
of blood supply like a muscle so you get
this this abnormal tissue that's not
very it's just like crabgrass in a
garden that starts growing in a
restricts motion and creates stiffness
and it starts growing around nerve roots
okay
not to mention that area of the body
starts to degenerate faster so you get
pinching on the nerve you get stiffness
and inflammation because it's not moving
anymore okay so that's old injuries
sugar why because it increases insulin
and you start developing a condition
called insulin resistance which one
characteristic of that is inflammation
just by getting this of a diet and
fixing into the resistance you can drop
inflammation way down in fact in a
minute fasting is a great way to improve
people with insulin resistance
specifically if they have a lot
inflammation okay before grains
especially the gluten that will create
inflammation in the gut but just grains
in general are tend to in quite
inflammation more than a lot of things
but the big one is the gluten if you
actually are consuming gluten right now
which is the protein in grains that
could be the reason why you have
inflammation
I mean I've have you taken people off
this off just grains in general and all
of the arthritis completely clears out
one actually I
there's actually 11 causes of
inflammation one is excessive alkalinity
if you're too alkaline okay what happens
is you are very susceptible to getting
allergies and inflammation and even if
you were to consume citrus which by the
way when you consume like orange or
lemons or grapefruits what happens in
your body that breaks down into it turns
into an acid but then it turns into a
very strong alkaline substance which
will then push you more into the
alkalinity and you'll find you have more
like stiffness or arthritis so if you
have that situation then you know your
body's too alkaline
all right vegetable oils like corn oil
and soy oil and safflower and sunflower
oil that is very very high in omega-6
it's more inflammation you need the
omega-3 fatty acids and that would be
the cod liver oil the fish oils okay you
can do also krill as well or DHA that's
a type of omega-3 fatty acid so
vegetable oil is very very thin like
you'd probably get that in salad
dressings or Mayo or even you would get
in like deep fried foods they bread and
they deep-fried like in corn oil you're
going to get a lot of inflammation after
you consume that alcohol that's a given
that's going to destroy your liver and
that will create inflammation Dairy
specifically grain fed grass-fed dairy
has a lot more omega-3 grain set which
is commercial is gives you a lot more
omega-6 fatty acid so if you're doing a
grass-fed dairy or animal product
chances are you're not going to have
near the inflammation and by the way
that trigger the memory great grains if
you were to consume kamut which is an
ancient grain you would have not nearly
have the amount of inflammation than you
would do the commercial weak to do now
so ancient grain significantly lower the
inflammation response to grains even
gluten okay there's people I even know
who can consume the ancient grains and
have no inflammation at all MSG
monosodium glutamate it's kind of a
neurotoxin but it enhances the flavor of
food
and it's definitely can create a lot of
fluid buildup and inflammation it says
this is a lot of the fast-food places
that you would go to ok 9 excessive
protein if you're doing large amounts of
protein that are going to be not
digested they're going to be a strain on
the liver in the kidney you can end up
with a lot of uric acid which turns into
gout which is a form of arthritis and
inflammation
okay so too much protein can mess with
your kidneys and now you're you're going
to have gout okay number 10 cooked foods
now one one meal of cook food is not
going to do anything I'm talking about
years of only eating your food
completely cooked or canned or
pasteurize why is that because when you
cook food you destroy the enzymes if
you're not eating anything raw like
vegetables for example which I know a
lot of people don't do that you're going
to wear out the liver the liver has to
then be depleted of its factors and also
the pancreas so you're going to start
having a bad liver and you're going to
get stiffness and arthritis just from
that alone so you want to start adding
more raw vegetables to your diet if you
go to some like Indian restaurants the
the vegetables are so cooked I mean it's
like completely dead that's what I'm
talking about okay in summary we need to
correct this we talked about the 11
causes of inflammation thank you so much
for watching hey guys thank you so much
for watching please click the subscribe
button and I will see you in the next
video